une production du studio sf
bio sans filtre le broadcast on parle de
ce qu'on veut nous inviter date si cette
suberbe avec moins d'une plante il on se
trouve en ce moment dans l'atelier nos
trois espaces ici au studio sfr un
espace qui est disponible pour location
ça vient avec la technique ça vient avec
nos techniciens ça vient avec le
matériel on s'occupe de tout vous n'avez
qu'à penser à votre contenu si vous
voulez plus d'infos écrivez-nous vos
infos à commerciale qui est coincé of
cette semaine cette semaine c'est le
grand retour de au lit avec anne harris
n'a pas de casque d'écouté que vous avez
aimé qu'on en fait il y a un an presque
un petit peu plus en tête et sous studio
la première fois qu'est venu le voir sa
bêtise super cool on avait parlé de ce
crime sexuel on avait parlé de relations
monogames couple ouvert aujourd'hui on a
abordé plein de différents sujets des
nouveaux sujets les schémas sexuelle le
sexe anal et 500 très excitant briques
certaine je souhaiterais le terrorisme
cet entrisme hélas à la différence à
20,9 gâche me et un orgasme
200 apprentis quoi ces termes le seco
soutient en principe le avec olic à mary
une équipe podcast en or et préparer
connaît son sujet et est à l'aise était
le cas elle est drôle c'était vraiment
un grand plaisir je pense que si pour la
dernière fois on avoir la tête à marie
non franchement ça vous attendront
vallée remercie une commande disparaît
l'ongle est au podcast de québec
le podcast ce sommet ne présentait pas
au soleil
le sponsor officiel de tout produit
alcool alcoolisées et non alcoolisées
ici aux sujets sensibles ou et le studio
vous avez accès à notre mini frigo avec
les produits à chaque pile après le
grand succès on est passé de leur sert
dur ils viennent de lancer une nouvelle
gamme de serveurs à base de votre donne
tout est enfin de sortir aussi déjà cédé
jeu c'est un acquis pour les gens que
vous devez sans fil mais tu as eu la
chance de goûter au vote que uncharted 2
[Musique]
j'adorais c'est un petit peu différent
justement je pense mais je pense que
j'aime encore plus un beau si je te jure
fait plus tôt les tabors de marc savard
des votes que mais ça l'a même goût
léger
c'est vraiment pas prononcé en alcool en
fait on coupe vraiment le bout de la
vodka comme tel c'est juste
rafraîchissant c'est juste léger un
petit goût de fruit c'est vraiment
agréable et les trous nouvelle sorte en
page on ne orange sanguine et on à
frambois framboise donc trop nouvelles
saveurs pour agrémenter votre équipe en
selle sur ce bord là kuzmanovic
se bas.xe
je pense qu'on va voir vraiment un bel
été avec h la pièce peas est disponible
à la saq fait que cours et nous en
procurer le podcast est présenté par nos
amis chez mindscape et c'est le retour
ultra semoule package qui avait disparu
pendant quelques mois mais il revient en
force outre ce mode paquet c'est quoi
c'est un petit rosoirs pour la précision
c'est un gel pour raser et c'est aussi
une expo lit à un exfoliant pour éviter
les poils incarnés parce que je sais que
des poils incarnés cas ça frotte ça
frotte pour le vrai d'hommes d'être un
adepte du ltro spectacle moi c'est ma
chanson préférée vraiment pour ali
3 est vraiment cette région le vraiment
région du centre comme on dit
voilà la bonne vieille et bouvier rasoa
à l'âme c'est ce que je préfère je
trouve que c'est s'ils veulent mieux si
ce qui fait la plus belle job c'est ce
qui le plus agréable pour moi fax au 8
août si ils y ont plané dans la douche
est vraiment mal et alexis malléable il
vaut vraiment super mini 10 mount eerie
le drassm où certains ultras ce
mouvement avec le gel puis avec les
accessoires ça rend l'expérience ultime
vous aurez jamais eu
cette région le aussi douce ou si ce que
c'est votre ville on a un code promo
pour vous qui est 20% de rabais avec la
livraison gratuite sur tous les produits
minsk et pas juste le trust me paquette
c'est le sans fil en un mot 20% de
rabais maison gratuite sors de là dessus
comme des pigeons sur les rites du mec
de
sa faute at-il
indiqué hier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en arrive là les
habitués
ouais ouais ça fait un an à peu près
j'étais venu à la fois ouais maintenant
à votre avis
demain
ça va super bien c'est pas bien et
beaucoup de choses se sont passées dans
la dernière année j'ai eu une ascension
assez rapide dans la première année de
mon entreprise on va tous connus comme
dans la deuxième moi et
regarder en arrière et c'est comme
regarder dans une tornade littéralement
donc ouais j'ai comme plein de choses
qui ont été mis en place et plein de
projets que j'ai développé des employés
plein plein de choses qui sont qui sont
en train de se réaliser dont je suis
vraiment vraiment fier et ontarien des
percées le monde de l'éducation sexuelle
je me suis justement dit quand tu étais
venu seul package est ainsi allé sur le
podcast des filles sexy rallye tt comme
partout le site était on dirait que j'en
sais pas comment tu faisais un niveau
énergie puis niveau en broderie qui fait
des trucs et podcasts fallait pas que ça
ça parait que travailler fort pour comme
construire ton affaire
ouais mais je me rappelle nicole toutes
les semaines il ya eu un jour je me
rappelle un genre de trois semaines
c'était connu six fois je pense de quoi
- belaud studio dans l'autre local afin
qu'ils étaient survenus dans ce local si
j'avais fait un peu de castes dans la
nouvelle salle est mais c'est la
première fois d'ailleurs est super des
locaux alors merci merci je commandais
tantôt le parquet avait fait avec nous
c'est ça a été en nous plus écoutée de
l'année 2021
comme de quoi que c'est un sujet qui
tellement qui attire tellement la
curiosité pil pil gens veulent en fait
apprendre qu'ils entendent parler de
sexe des relations parce que ces six
universités
oui mais tous les êtres humains ont une
sexualité même l'absence de sexualité
est une forme de sexualité
je pense qu'il ya tellement de mythes
qui existe qui persiste que les gens
vivent sont justes année il va juste
comprendre leur corps puisque d'ailleurs
c'est les sujets les plus recherchés
utiles à la compréhension du
fonctionnement incorporez-les
physiologique biologique on parle
direction d'orgasme de point g des
clitoris on parle d'éjaculation féminine
l'on parlait les gens veulent juste
comprendre comment leur corps fonctionne
cette information le est pas accessible
nulle part le plus grosse source
d'éducation c'est là pour nous donc var
qui tourne vers quoi tu te tournes dans
les écoles on parle pas de ces choses là
qui si on en parle on en parle pas dans
une perspective où on peut inclure le
plaisir on va te faire part avec le tsl
on va se faire peur avec les grossesses
non désirées on va taper avec la
première fois ça va déchirer ça va
saigner pitt soit perdre quelque chose
alors qu'on gagne en expérience je te
dit épanoui en tant qu'être humain donc
il ya peu de source d'éducation à la
sexualité je pense que c'est ce qui fait
un peu le succès aussi de la page au lit
avec anne marie puis des podcasts que je
fais que je fais est pire oui vraiment
le ce que tu viens de dire le l'espèce
de
d'éducation sexuelle par l'apport le mot
c'est exactement mon expérience c'est
précisément sur le cje à
un point tel que comme tu veux pas avoir
de relations sexuelles à cause de trop
peur d'attraper quelque chose là que ce
n'est que de sa comparse en mouvement ou
secondaire le il me semble que ce
n'était que secondaire du côté sexuel
c'était juste l'itc c'est comme peace
hills et c'est la pire chose la
sexualité tout comme la pire partie le
web et c'est même pas la plus grande
partie non ce soit et je me rappelle il
y avait des images horribles de stade
très avancé de syphilis et de gonorrhée
avec des espèces de déformation du
visage tellement que tu étais avant ses
notes à syfy l'esprit parce que oui ça
existe mais jeudi on peux tu parler du
pourcentage de gens qui ont du plaisir
qu'ils vont s'aimer ce pays qui vont
s'amuser et se découvrir à travers ce
thème est le condom sur une banale si
j'ai vu sur l'avant bras complet même
preuve d'un moral
elle avait dit à l'ats voulait prouver
au fait que les feuilles si votre chat
me dit que c'est trop serré les regarder
se placer bien qu ont donc jusqu'à son
jusqu'à son club avait dit six voitures
nier ta machine même idyllique avait dit
comme s'il est vraiment comme une grosse
grille inversée voyons non j'aime j'aime
ça je regarde c'est comme telle des
gamins solaire
la preuve d'un moral en plus c'est comme
quest pourquoi c'était elle qui revient
la charge de nous parler d'eux c'est
exactement ce et puis moi ce qu'est ce
que ça m'amène à penser c'est que al
hawthi vécu une expérience négative et
elle avec ce puits à le projeter seul
dans son éducation qui on devrait peut
si je parle pas ma vie sexuelle sur les
réseaux sociaux le sait très rock si
j'en passe parce que je sais que ça les
amène un point est positive et le juste
ton expérience la toile exact c'est
important de rester une heure dans cette
éducation la puisaye peut transmettre
c'est difficile parce que on est éduqué
on est on est on est programmé de
différentes façons selon notre culture
notre religion selon de où il vient
selon nos par heure selon bien des
affaires si elle accepte de parler des
jugements de valeur dans l'information
tu transmets mes ce c'est clairement une
expérience qu'elle obéit type qui a fait
que de la gagne ça vous arrivera pas
arrêté de les croire ils vont vous
bullshit et
commun comme alexandre champagne quand
qui allaient dans les lives de personnes
a fait son personnage mettant son corps
ne sont ni soufflé
gonflé
pour un film aussi mais j'ai juste parce
que je trouvais ça drôle mais oui
effectivement le monde son corps oui
j'avoue mais c'est vrai que ces
arguments le qui revient souvent
l'histoire de hausse trop eric
charrier
ouais ouais moi j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
à cause de cela à cause de deux là la
peur bleue comme avait mis des hits et
ssg pas eu beaucoup de relations sans
condom et on sait jamais un problème non
plus le titan mettons la mettez un fuel
et j'avais dû me trouver des raisons
jusqu'à ce que
je prenne un peu d'âge
puis que depuis que l'oeuf je décide de
me faire bon mais on va passer cette
étape le plus rapidement dans un genre
de dans la game de dating don de faire
ce intelligemment en
quantité passée l'étape plus rapidement
s'cusez moi je qu'est ce que tu viens
d'avoir la discussion d'avoir la
discussion de petits sans nécessairement
aller passer un test les deux types
l'attendait résultat d'avoir la diction
9 arrêts comme le genre ça fait trois
quatre fois puis comme doigts de ce
texte on a une conversation en être le
puits de faire confiance à l'autre
personne aussi même si jack guez que
techniquement faudrait que tu fasses tes
styles des deux mais c'était encore une
fois ces genres c'est le réflexe que
j'ai à cause de ce que je me suis dit
dans lequel j'étais au secondaire c'est
genre ultra ultra safe le de faire ce
genre mais je vois là les attractions
qui ont fait de moi l'idée de l'homme
avancer dans ce dossier là sauf que sera
sifflée polar non non non et non non
mais c'était plus dans le sens pour les
médias les infections transmises mais
c'est un bon point taverne parce qu'il
ya des gens qui m'ont pas recette c'est
la première fois ils vont se protéger -
plein car ça fait justement 3 4 fois 100
comme on sait confiance maintenant on
est rentré dans le train d'imiter on
sait qui on enlève on enlève la
protection - mais c'est quoi la santa
première puis l'a3 quatrième fois bah
y'en a pas c'est juste que tu as une
conversation jusque dans une
conversation pitt accepte de faire
confiance à l'autre personne ouais
d'avoir que l'autre personne a une
sexualité synpics n en prend soin mais
je comprends qu'il ya aucune différence
entre la première fois sauf que la
première fois tu connais pas aux
personnes la pratiquent
déjà qu'ils vont penser ça mais je sais
pas si je vous ai déjà posé la question
mais est ce que vous savez c'est quoi le
symptôme le plus commun de toutes les
unités ssd infections transmises
sexuellement et par le sang et veulent
le symptôme les symptômes et puis comme
un autre emploi ou qu'on les symptômes
les plus communs
oui je sais pas question piège l'absence
de symptômes l'absence de cinq ans
avec sa pipe à sa gratte ça chauffe pour
sa coulpe au est donc souvent on n'aura
pas de symptômes comme des infections
transmises sexuellement
donc c'est important de faire re testé
quand il faudrait faire comme à tous les
partenaires sociaux mais là aussi je
peux comprendre que c'est pas tout le
monde qui a envie de faire ça mais c'est
cool maintenant parce qu'avant c'est
elle qui était plus value right qui met
la main dessus non c'est dur
ça se peut que ce à des coûts réduits à
lille
j'ai pas de pénis sa main droite sociale
c'est pas parce qu'il est petit on
connaît pas le contenu exact
et ça c'est vraiment on va parler de
moutons d'herpès ya des gens qui sont
comme moi j'ai jamais eu de
manifestation éleveurs de toute ma vie
c'est sûr sûr sûr j'ai jamais été avec
quelqu'un qui avait des manifestations
et et erreur puisque moi mais ça veut
rien dire non mais je te le dis le moi y
ait jamais je comprends mais on est
soixante dix pour cent la population à
voir le virus qui est
dispensé 72% we be et génitale c'est une
personne sur sept au canada
donc c'est beaucoup de monde dessus
beaucoup de monde dit jamais deux fois
par quelqu'un qui a contracté l'herpès
puisqu'elle personnes de cette personne
vous dire j'ai french le sauvage m'ont
jamais personne qui veut dire donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui se transmet
de façon insidieuse sans savoir il ne
peut pas savoir s'ils quittaient le
transmit parce que sa spectaculaire dans
le toit depuis dix ans j'aurais pu que
les revenus voilà ouais donc messi a
fait la journée
aux personnes non je suis quelqu'un qui
met on va avoir un résultat positif
d'herpès c'est tellement mieux quelqu'un
qui ne sait pas parce que cette personne
à contrôler ses poussées si l emmena
parce que c'est très peu de gens qui ont
des manifestations physiques et ravaux
contrôler seul avec peut-être la
prophylaxie mme prise des médicaments
tous les jours
donc et puis alors 1 % de chances de le
transmettre si je te dis ok photo
perrine même atteint 1% de chance de pas
très veiller à ce que tous péri
toutes les discussions autour du
du condom répit dans les lits
mouvementée mis tout ce qu'ils les
témoignages qu'on voyait souvent c'était
des affaires de condom vraiment souvent
dans l'allégorie environ condom en cinq
ans que je le vois sans que je le sache
rien si tu es vraiment proposer des
condoms ça m'a surpris à quel point
là-bas pisam aussi fait réaliser à quel
point c'est important d'edf
cause de respecter ses deux métiers de
ça se voit comme une base des normes le
pis ça qu'on n'a pas besoin de voir
défense ou de voir questionner si à
chaque fois ça s'appelle du stenting 1
c'est une pratique qui est vraiment très
très tendance et chez les jeunes donc de
commencer dans mes rapports sexuels avec
le condom et de l'enlever sans que
personne ne s'en rende compte par le
rapport sexuel mais là c'est comme ça
enlève une partie de consentement
quantifier c'est parce qu'elle a
ressenti une certaine condition qu'elle
respecte pas consenti au départ ci avait
pas eu de cadeau
moi aussi j'avais été surpris de voir à
quel point ça revenait souvent dans tout
les témoignages convoyer les témoignages
anonymes ce genre d'affaires le sur des
piges
croyez-moi parole l'été ou palais vous
faites ce que vous voulez sauf que j'en
sais même pas quelque chose qui me
guette déjà traversé l'esprit laitiers
de faire seul
mais à gasquet
sur ta sur la plateforme dans le fond le
explique moi qu'est ce qu'est ce que tu
fais qu'est ce que c'est déjà qu'ils
nous écoutent aussi qu'ils le tuent
parle de mon instagram tu parles des
noms sa plateforme d'accompagnement
ouais enfin que d'en forger l
accompagnement et qui s'appelle réponse
sexuelle sur cette plateforme le gia
toutes les semaines des ateliers qui
sortent sur des sujets pour lesquels je
me fais poser constants les mannequins
ces ateliers que toi tu donnes way que m
maintenant j blige et des sexologues qui
m'aident à offrir les ateliers et on est
en ça fait un an que la plateforme
existe et donc on a parlé du désir
sexuel d'un communication on a parlé de
l'orgasme deux mois de temps parce que
les gens ont beaucoup de questions sur
l'orgasme on a parlé d'attentât n'a mis
la main tommy parce que les gens ont
besoin de comprendre leur corps si tu
veux avoir des orgasmes ça c'est quelque
chose qui me surprend tout le temps et
les gens ne se sont jamais regarder dans
un miroir n'eut plus je dis les gens
c'est surtout les personnes ayant en
revanche chez les femmes et puis après
ça ils s'attendent à avoir un orgasme
puis je me dis mais il faut comme que tu
puisse comprendre qu est ce qui l homme
il voir the bean donc
pleinement ont fait le mode du tantrisme
en ce moment et pour avoir une meilleure
connexion avec soin avec quels sont ses
partenaires donc à tous les mois à
toutes les semaines on sort des ateliers
oui on veut revenir sur ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il ya des outils introspectif à
part faire tout ce que je faisais en
consultation je le style est question
revienne dans mes consultations il vient
sur instagram y revient dans les
podcasts pack pourquoi pas offrir les
outils un coup vraiment entrer vraiment
très moins élevés demandés mot
revient donc et c'est vraiment ceci
vient voir consultation je te donne des
outils de même avoir une consultation
jeté du que sur le sujet parce que selon
moi il ya un très grand pouvoir de
transformation à travers l'éducation
donc c'est ce qui se passe sur cette
plate forme le et il ya des femmes qui
ont atteint l'orgasme pour la première
fois grâce à cette plateforme une
reconnexion avec quand même gratifiant
le quand tu reçois un message ce pays je
voudrais
maintenant d'aider des femmes dans 30
une quarantaine d et entre 20 et 46 sur
tous ces gens mais je rejoins depuis
qu'ils ont qui atteignent l'orgasme pour
la première fois
que tu es nous pour des hommes c'est
plate mais j'en sais même plus basse et
plus c'est le fun en même temps mais je
ne sais même plus une question le tir on
atteint l'orgasme on a tous déjà atteint
l'orgasme et on sait comment atteindre
l'orgasme après l'orgasme en dormant
cpo quelque chose qui ait cliqué
difficile à atteindre le milieu
climatique est dépensé pour certaines
personnes puis surtout des femmes
s'assoient comme quelque chose qui ont
jamais vécu ou de aussi disent ils une
accessible c'est quand même
c'est fou c'est fou maison j'ai fait un
corner que ce matin à la radio est sûre
justement les et ravir aux tic qui
aiment les orgasmes nocturne c'est 80 %
des sommes qui vont avoir des orgasmes
nocturne vers 6 40% des femmes
gamme le sommet ouais mais j'ai
l'impression que l'homme l'organe est à
l'extérieur du corps puis les femmes
c'est plus comme le clitoris est
majoritairement interne ce qui fait
qu'il est moins facile d'accès puis on a
plus d' incompréhension par rapport à
comment les stimuler
donc j'ai l'impression que ça joue un
peu contre comme nous finalement ouais
parce que probablement de mon expérience
les rêves que je fais des rêves vraiment
graphique puis-je exactement mais ton
caisse dans vie mais ton mais mon
conscient et mon second set au courant
de quoi faire pour atteindre l'orgasme
et on fait quand je dors c'est sûr que
mon rêve ça envoie directement dans
cette direction là mais j'imagine qu'ils
aient effectivement quand et moi au
courant tu sais pas trop comment ça
marche tant que leur avis je serai
produire des idées tout fait ou des
vecteurs vue puis des trucs qui au final
tu amènes pas à bon port
tu parlais du mois du tantrisme mais
c'est quoi le tantrisme c'est quoi le
sec le sexe tantrique moi de mon open de
mon point de vue externe d'un geek
connaît focale seul système le chanteur
de police qui est capable de comme four
et pendant des heures et des heures et
des heures sans jamais perdre une
élection bien un atteignant l'orgasme
sens d'éjaculation puis comme si
risqué on est très loin ou est ce qu on
est très loin avec histoire de sting est
un peu seul simpliste c'était absolument
stars casting c'est comme ces documents
c'est vrai le respect des rumeurs autour
de sting et qu'ils leur fassent et même
de son propre aveu ouais c'est la parole
les gens qui écoutent les piquets
sauteront pas car tu te fais des heures
et des heures d'abord on généralise pour
qui je dis je pense qu'elle rapports
sexuels et les femmes le taux qu'on
parle dans un monde binaire et rôles m
les femmes c'est environ sept minutes un
rapport sexuel satisfaisant le kef a
besoin de se faire ramoner
portier le mauvais
un terme
non mais et
puis vous savez j'ai commencé je
mentionne tout le temps la pénétration
le siphonneur
en fait je pense que si on peut se le
tantrisme
cmcc il aime
de joindre tous les sens des capable
d'aider
j'ai pas le mot qui montrent le sait
vraiment comme des capable de vivre dans
tout les sens d'allumer toute essence
c'est d'être avec le corps l'esprit et
ce qui t'entoure s est très spirituelle
comme pratique ça vient du bouddhisme et
de l'hindouisme
mais c'est vraiment d'être capable
d'être à 100% dans le moment présent ça
fait juste du sens dans le fond parce
que plus tu es dans le moment présent
plus tu es capable de ressentir les
sensations sur ton corps puis à la fin
de la journée on est des êtres programmé
pour le plaisir pour ressentir le
plaisir qu'il ya plein de monde qui sont
pas casting qui nous écoutent pics on
peut garder ressentir du plaisir lors
des rapports sexuels pourquoi sont pas
dans le moment présent sa valeur peut
être sont en train de penser à la
performance sont en train de la faire
le tantrisme c'est vraiment des capable
de revenir à ce qui se passe ici
maintenant c'est d'être capable de
joindre le corps et l'esprit des alignés
et de ses des pratiques t1 les exercices
que je donne à faire que les gens sont
comme et jamais de la vie c'est la base
n'a pas besoin de jouer
t'as pas besoin d'aidés du livre du kama
sutra
se regardent dans les yeux juste
regarder quelqu'un dans les yeux des
fois ça peut être super déstabilisant je
fais dans des retraites j'anime des
retraites avec deux chats yoga puis en
fait à gas inc puis les gens pleurent
rient sont déstabilisés complètement des
deux minutes deux peuples se regarde
dans les yeux comme aux michael matheson
nu avec ton ta partenaire y être en
l'humain les pieds nus je prends les
pieds limited que les mains les pieds
c'est avec ton ta partie du tube qui est
comme si ce domaine 16h05 dix orteils
coller mais les pilotes regarde dans les
yeux puis une fois que tu étais de
venise avec ce petit match tant
respiration
ça crée une espèce de bulle sur revient
dans le moment présent petit tellement
concentrés sur leurs gardes sur la
respiration tu peux pas faire autrement
que d'être ici
fax à l'accentuer fois mille les
sensations qui peuvent survenir après
plus tu peux commencer le rapport sexuel
en continuant à marcher leur respiration
peut
s'embrasser entre regardant dans les
yeux tout faire en regardant dans les
yeux ça rapporte tellement une intensité
ceci est une partie du tantrisme
le tantrisme on va vraiment c'est quand
on a c'est ça la sexualité parce que
c'est souvent de 7 dans cette optique là
qu'on en parle si ça pète et dans toutes
les sphères de ta vie c'est juste d'être
dans le moment présent
connecté avec tout exactement eqt et
puis ici de genre de taper une forme de
méditation en même temps dans la
sexualité
exact pi2 d'être en connexion avec toi
même mais genre est appartenant aussi
j'imagine et s'était plus aligné
connectés way oui parce qu'à la fin de
la journée c'est ce que tu veux vivre
dans un rapport sexuel si tu veux avoir
du plaisir puis on a six tellement ceux
à avoir un orgasme lui-même jégou dire
d'avoir un orgasme je sais pas si on
avait déjà parlé de la distinction
l'organe de l'orgasme et non non non
qu'est donc leur caste et ça va vraiment
à toutes tes sensations physiologique ça
va être
la montée des tensions jusqu'au point
culminant est imminent ça va être comme
la sensation au niveau des organes
génitaux c'est encore c'était son taux
plancher pelvien c'est tout ce qui est
vraiment physique mais l'orgasme est une
composante qui émotionnel donc souvent
dans les rapports sexuels on est
tellement focus et sur l'orgasme qu'on
se rend même pas compte qu'on n'a pas
d'orgasme
puis on veut on veut arriver à avoir un
orgasme un orgasme c'est comme ça péter
dans le cerveau le en plus de pétiller
dans les organes génitaux il sait comme
c'est encore au complet c'est ton être
c'est émotif qui s'il ya des gens qui
vont pleurer ou rire après avoir eu un
orgasme parce que c'est tellement
d'émotion en même temps une explosion
d'émotions mais il ya plein de gens qui
vont jamais le vivre parce qu'ils sont
tellement concentrée sur la technicalité
puis des organes génitaux et tous ceux
donc d'être capable de pratiquer des
choses des pratiques comme le tantrisme
vélo ça t'amène ça t'amène plus loin
dans tes sensations qui dans tellement
de styles de sexualité je parle mais on
prépare les deux schémas érotique seuil
est un schéma énergique tant ses mains
un schéma sensuelle sexuelle coquin et
métamorphe qu'on appelle je voulais
poser question parce que j'ai vu c'est
un citoyen sa g ce qui je m'entends
ouais
c'est révolutionnaire et cinq types de
2,5 type de manière de vivre sa
sexualité ou préférence un
fax et 5g goût des personnalités et
puis c'est pas moi qui ai inventé ce la
personne qui est à la tête de tout ça
s'appelle jahia ma s et une sexologue
clinicienne que ça fait des décennies
qu'il a étudié ses clients qu'il ya des
gens qui vont la voir pour savoir je
comprends pas je me comprends pas
sexuellement mais des fois on sait même
pas qu'on se comprend pas et je me sens
incompatible avec mon partenaire et on
est dans une impasse qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est juste que vous parlez pas le
même langage et vous avez pas la même
personnalité sexuelle c'est pas parce
qu'on n'a pas la même personnalité
sexuelle qu'on est automatiquement
incompatibles mais c'est comme les cinq
langage de l'amour
comme j'aime enseigner ton énergique
sensuelle sexuelle qu'aucun en avc king
qui ça se rapporte aux fétiches tout ce
qui est à bout des métamorphes mais ta
mort s'est littéralement tu es égale
tous les autres que j'ai nommé avant de
passer dans l'autre jeune août et en
même temps les quatre ter est exact et
en même temps les quatre vingts été très
c'est ce genre et c'est le partenaire la
partenaire que tu peux avoir parce que
c'est sûr qu'à vos si ce match et
matière il a way puis on peut tous les
décrire un peu
donc le premier c'est énergique et ça
c'est des personnes qui vont être
capables d'expérimenter des orgasmes
sans nécessairement se faire toucher
payer des gens comme eux mêmes pauvres
mais oui parce qu'on a parlé d'orgasme
nocturne tantôt
on a parlé de sting
on a aussi on peut aussi aller écouter
la saison d'occupation de ben ali ou est
ce qui est un bel exemple
d'orgasme saint saëns touchés on
peut venir parce que
mais oui mais c'est exactement ça c'est
l'état de kundalini là qu'on appelle
enfin les gens c'est difficile à
comprendre parce que les gens sont comme
oui mais est ce que ça implique un
orgasme des organes génitaux
un orgasme
c'est que ça implique pas nécessairement
les organes génitaux dit je me rappelle
j'avais un prof qui me disait ce grand
club d'europe d'un orgasme c'est validé
on se rappelle de notre prof de morale
qui elle s'était entre les deux doigts
c'est vrai c'est la même programme en
off à l'arrêt pour changer de vitesse
attaquants sont famille de flat il
ya fallu 40 pialat la thaïlande
tu passes à la main leur casse même si
genre c'est le sale allume complètement
faux que je comprenne qui sait qui
on la salue d'ailleurs mais avoue dans
l'école wasterlain cours le site est la
seule la seule année où est-ce qu'on
était les deux dans le même club mais je
passe puis mais qui continuait à quai
est-ce que tu mais si tu
te pose cette question parce que six ans
mais tant qu'un prof comme prof raconte
vacances et d'expériences personnelles
dans ça dépend dans quel contexte
peut-être un contexte on parlait de ses
7 points cours de mars
à mai au nom d'allah mais
non mais non puis je reçois écoute chose
de correct parce que je pense que
c'était maintenant elle raconté cette
expérience personnelle en disant que
tous les tous les corps et les désirs
était différent maintenant son point qui
s'était justement ce pas parce que il ya
d'autres manières des
civils
comme ça exemple personnel mais on rit
de cette prof là mais bon c'est trop
flambé de 6 ces trucs là mais c'était
vraiment
aujourd'hui vous vous auriez
probablement pas la même réaction pour
écarter à tout comme si comment sa
sexualité comme les adultes qui font du
sexe sont comme des gueux le team ces
facs m mais oui effectivement c'est
vallée de l'authie si elle salue comme
spark quelque chose à l'intérieur des
salles allumé quelque chose why not donc
il ya des gens qui sans même être
touchés peuvent atteindre l'orgasme et
j'imagine oui c'est pas c'est pas juste
que ces personnes sont comme ceux
j'imagine que si ça se développe oui il
ya des gens qui sont comme ceux qui
savent pas qu'ils souffrent dans leur
sexualité présentement parce que ils
n'ont jamais été capables d'aller
explorer cet aspect là de leur sexualité
parce que on est tellement mis dans des
boîtes on nous dit que c'est en prirent
pas dessert donc on fait entrer repos
désert plomb sans briser à travers ce
script le alors qu'on l'ait poussé
jusqu'aux on n'exploite pas de sécurité
de la bonne façon donc énergique et
épices et des gens il ya toujours ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que toujours un
côté positif qui a un côté négatif à
chaque schéma fac donc ton côté positif
qui atteignent l'orgasme m sans être
touché ms et des personnes qui savent
déjà envie de rester par un carré à
quelqu'un qui comme qui c'est qui qui
sera aussi facilement oui
quelqu'un qui se parent sensible avec
l'énergie des autres donc si on va
trouver trop rapidement par les organes
génitaux cette personne ne va se
raffermit et donc ça peut être difficile
pour ces personnes-là de vraiment un
monde sexuellement ça leur prend même
l'anticipation williams la distancer
m.le tease ses rangs des gens qui vont
être excité dans l'espace
temps sensuelle je suis sensuelle et
c'est vraiment et déjà qu'ils sont
vraiment allumé par tout les sens donc
c'est moi je peux manger quelque chose
peut faire qu'un omagad j'ai eu un
orgasme culinaire en ce moment c'est
trop bon c'est trop bon j'ai apprécié
comme les goûts dans ma bouche mais
c'est le cas leur side l'autre côté des
rails c'est qu'il ya des odeurs intime
parle qui complètent mal je peux pas
beaucoup
mais c'est des gens qui on aime avant
tout c'est comme j'aime beaucoup les
préliminaires que c'est des gens qui
vont vraiment aimé ça prend l'artère qui
vont aimer ça elle sa part touché
beaucoup le touch est super important
s'embrasser comme la valse le est
quasiment plus important que le rapport
sexuel en tant que tel
mais de l'autre côté justement c'est des
personnes qui sont beaucoup dans leur
tête parce qu'elles sont tellement
allumé par toutes les distances que si
matin ya un tas de linge sale à terre ça
se peut même en tapant sur mer et à
terre puis que si une odeur que j'aime
pas je pense juste à l'odeur que j'aime
pas
la musique est bonne si la télé joue
aussi ça se peut que ça vienne vraiment
me dérangeait pas content que je pète
allumé par vraiment beaucoup de choses
je peux être étendue par vraiment
beaucoup de choses aussi c'est les gens
qui se parlent le plus dans leur tête
c'est des gens qui vont au delà du
cliché de la difficulté des fois
atteindre l'orgasme parce qu'ils sont
communs sur le point plus tarder ça
parce que les biens de penser à quelque
chose
effectivement avec lima un petit
sexuelle qui justement les
savait surtout les hommes qui vont être
dans ce schéma là par défaut parce que
c'est ce qu'on leur apprendre donc très
axé sur les organes génitaux
on est vraiment dans le
on est vraiment dans l'orgasme on va
avoir un orgasme ont scié pas d'orgasme
monique pas satisfaits et s'est déjà
souvent qui vont et mac il toute la
beauté du paysage pour se rendre à
destination
elle trouvait enfin le contraire de
l'alchimiste
ben le contrat du sang sur les mains
ouais ça s'appelle dc1 essentielle
prince excellent ensemble parce que
c'est comme ça va trop vite pour le
sensuel et les sexualités colline par
quatre chemins c'est une
exacte du compte nos cantines ont
apprécié chez les kings qui est copains
coquins c est tout qu'est-ce qui est
relié au tabou fac et tisci tabou pour
moi n'est pas insurmontable pour toi
pour toi fais que me trompe moi en
missionnaire c'est vraiment un exemple
et je trouve ce tabou belle le sama
foule excitée parce que longtemps
missionnaire je trouve ça taboubi fac
des fois le le contexte est plus
important pour eux que
l'acte en tant que telle fac par exemple
on s'embrasse mais on est dans un lieu
inusité le parce qu'on est dans un lieu
visité je trouve vraiment bon le baiser
mais si on avait une même baiser dans
une chambre à coucher qui pour moi pour
un ordre tabou ben je leur ai moins
apprécié avec talking quitte le coq et
psychologique que le coquen plus
physiologique avec des gens qui vont
aimer ce par des jurys de domination
qui vont aimer c'est jouer avec les
sensations du corps et sa tâche et jouer
avec la température gtrra et le sofa
attention le côté négatif c'est que
c'est des gens qui peuvent avoir juste
comme une route pour se rendre à
l'orgasme maxi fuchs porte par exemple
un chapeau de cow boy pour avoir un
orgasme s'ils s'imposent et que je
prêche pas pourquoi j'irai prendre
quelque chose de plus un bâtard un
imperméable qu'il pleuve toi ça te prend
ça pour avoir le regard on avoir tout le
temps ses limites ses limites et puis
est-ce que c'est des personnes sont
toujours attirés vers la nouveauté ouais
parce que tu es un tabou a amené plus tu
l'expérimentent moins de vingt tableaux
à dieu ça prend des années pour ces
personnes le est pour perfectionner les
scénario idéal qui les amène à un espèce
d'extase fac oui a toujours des choses
qu'on peut ramener la nouveauté et
cherop cd et déjà commencé mais c'est la
gagne de fokine mais vraiment pas cessé
les gens c'est prouvé les étudiants ont
prouvé que c'est les gens qui ont les
meilleures capacités de communication et
c'est les gens qui vont et
qui vont avoir le plus d'empathie parce
que quand tu es dans le tabou de poche
choix dans des discussions au préalable
pour savoir sont où les limites
personnelles de chacun des partenaires
qui prend part aux rapports sexuels de
pochade être empathique de pêche voie de
respecter les limites de l'autre alors
qu'on n'a jamais dit si on le canton on
est deux sexuelle mais il va par le on
fait entrer repos des sacs on est bien
content
justement d'identité mettant les
communautés bdsm ce la communication est
super valoriser puisse faire normalisé
aussi parce que
dans la moyenne du fait qu'ils imaginent
que justement t'as pas le choix d'avoir
qu'ils écoutent les préférences écoute
qu'elle jouait samedi pour que
c'est un bon film si tout le monde à
l'aise avec tout non exactes vite et
c'est des gens c'est qu'ils vont m a
vendu acheté qu'est ce qu'on appelle
puis cela s'est un moment après le
rapport sexuel qui peut être hyper
intense psychologiquement au même
physiquement bon moment pour revenir
bien on fait pas souvent ce après les
rapports sexuels surtout quand c'est
quelqu'un comme que 6 me dont la
première fois qu'un rapport avait un coq
et voilà je prends pas le temps de
descendre de ce qui vient d'arriver ici
mais eux c'est vraiment important pour
rld est capable de faire ce puits chaud
que ça alimente le désir d'être capable
de faire ce qui leur pend ça qu'est ce
qui est arrivé aux pensées dehors de son
monopole ou jusqu'à avoir un moment de
connexion un moment de connexion que ce
soit d'en parler ou que ce soit des
justes comme revenir physiquement dans
l'espace dans la réalité en dehors du
scénario donc cesser si on les juge
beaucoup ces gens l'homme et c'est des
gens qui sont hyper épanoui sexuellement
en général général qui après tu le les
métamorphes en anglais ça s'appelle
shape shifter et puis comme j'ai
mentionné s'était littéralement toutes
les autres que je viens de nommer se
reconnaît dans tous les autres également
le pot 1 ou 2 sont évidemment les quatre
ça fait des départements seront
extraordinaires mais en contrepartie ils
y ont tout les points négatifs aussi que
les autres mais qui plus est ce que tu
es soit 1 où les quatre
[Musique]
piles on évolue à notre excellent t elle
évolue donc et je pense que si on a
quand même un schéma primaire et après
ce espère développer d autres schémas
donc par exemple quelqu'un qui mentent
aujourd'hui j'aimerais avoir un orgasme
énergie énergétique mais je peux le
travail mais ça prend du temps que ça
prend la patience pas tout le monde qui
a envie d'investir ce temps le dans leur
sexualité pour avoir du plaisir alors
que quand le monde avait tellement tente
où tu disais c'est pas parce qu'on est
pas le même schéma que si vous allez
chez que ce qu'est ce qu'on fait mais
tonkin qe1 et le quatrième je me suis
dit non matière sexuelle le sensuel
piloterez le tabou le témoin comment
contrer concilie ce métier par exemple
sensuelle te dis sensuelle et tabou
c'est tellement facile de trouver des
choses qu'on est capables de faire
ensemble parce que l'essentiel la chèvre
juste devant coin la pièce
non mais sait on parlait dernier des
accessoires s'appelle juste comme une
plume ça peut être pilot l'essentiel
aime se se faire toucher m.sow vivre des
sensations sur son corps pour la
personne qui est dans les mêmes que dans
le tabou de votre été remis un objet que
pour lui ou elle est à bout donc peut
amener ça avec la sensuelle ils vont
découvrir des sensations donc il ya
toujours moyen de trouver un terrain
d'entente entre les deux
puis j'ai remarqué que souvent quand un
schéma primaire est comblé
après ça devient facile de t'ouvrir aux
autres schémas donc si tu es avec un ou
une partenaire qui est différent de toi
de combler son schéma faire en sorte que
le partenaire semences s'ouvrir aux
autres schémas donc s'ouvre à par
conséquent à temps chez moi aussi je
comprends
tout ça mais
moi maintenant je l'appelais quand même
à ma vie mais ton père mais
relation passée maintenant le pi
chemin maintenant après t'avoir temps
discuter tout ça je suis capable de
vraiment mieux expliquer pourquoi dans
une relation passée c'était la sexualité
tu es quand même même pas problématique
mais tu es loin d'être
satisfaisante pour tout le monde le dit
puis pourquoi dans une autre relation
après c'était quand même marqué le genre
pire même plastique puis pilule
maintenant la grèce que le ménage soit
capable de le verbaliser mettons là sauf
que c'est quand même
ce quand même chiant team est tombé
c'est quand même chose quand même touché
parce que ce site ait pas sur le même
schéma hausse
ça peut être poche le silence et
la sexualité poche ses poches le way
mais je pense que tu es mosquée moi ce
que j'ai
ce que je remarque quand tu dis si tu
sais à quel point justement il ya des
différences d'une personne à l'autre
dans comment confiné sexualité du conte
qu'on veut la ville petit quand c'est
moi ça mousse et m'est arrivé émettons
d'être en relation plus pendant des
années ti sur une certaine longueur
d'onde avec ta partenaire puis mettons
que chez polydor les données sexuelle
belle à la sexualité ça se passe comme
ça
peu tard et avec une nouvelle personne
qui
cité pour toi la sexualité c'est comme
ça c'est toujours été comme ce puits la
personne de victor était tout le temps
été satisfaite que ce soit comme ce sera
celle de penser que non mais si je
reproduis ça va fonctionner la personne
doit être satisfait depuis le fait ce
que finalement c'est comme
ça a pas le résultat comptait
justement pour des rencontres annuelles
de plusieurs partenaires veut pocketbook
et c'est vraiment différent à l'autre et
man city de telle manière de toucher
comme sud avec terrain jouer pour jouer
dix blessés comme acquis et non comme ce
prix à fond la carte indiqué mme
doumenjou ce match et c'est comme ça
qu'il ya vraiment large éventail de
possibilités
qui de l'eau justement que ces
commerçants en ciel en fête et le plus
tôt possible dans disques eu d'abord un
sinon c'est trop facile déjà pensé que
la manière qui est moins habitué ou la
manière qui était la dernière personne à
qui j'ai fait dessus c'était comme ça
que ça marche et puis l'autre elle avait
d'autres un autre véhicule puis d'autres
préférences puis de ça ça peut vraiment
ne pas fonctionner depuis même causer
des malentendus l'un tient pas compte à
nouveau j'ai envie de répondre de choses
assez hockey d'une part je pense qu'il
ya des gens qui vont être connus dans
les schémas pontiac et moi je suis comme
ça
puis je pense que effectivement c'est
comme quand avec un pic ça marche parce
que vous êtes le même schéma c'est comme
soulagé
en fait compatibles mais qu'est ce qui
dit que tu aimerais pas autre chose
parce que chaque personne est différente
mais chaque personne te fait découvrir
des choses aussi des gens avec qui tu es
moins compatibles via des gens avec qui
tu es plus compatibles fac ça fait en
sorte que tu découvres à chaque personne
je serai ton premier rapport sexuel
versus ton 30e
c'est peu de chose cet été de plus au
courant de ce que tu aimes de ce qu est
un peu puis je pense que chaque personne
comme une richesse a amené aux rapports
sexuels est ce ça passe par mon deuxième
point qui la communication puis comme tu
dis il faut en parler plus tôt que tard
parce que on attend toujours qu'il ya
des problèmes avant de parler de la
sexualité et le msp fait des années
qu'on se côtoie fait des années qu'on
fait du sexe ensemble la même façon
parce que clairement on a trouvé les
chemins fois que l'on fait pas d'autre
chose que ce chemin le la plupart du
temps en général qui le on se parle peu
on a des rapports sexuels dans le
silence on sera payé en vie nos vies il
offre d'en parler parce que là je me
rends compte que je pense que j'ai envie
de découvrir autre chose comment ce que
je fais pour en parler oups j'ai fait
qu'il orgasme pendant des années comment
ce que je fais pour en parler j'ai
emmené le demande qui vient d'avoir qui
ne commencerait le maintenant là pour
expliquer
le sud ouest et on en avait parlé aussi
quand tu étais venu dans leur foi qui
sait que c'était plus on attend
justement plus extrêmement difficile ça
fait trois ans et comme tout ce qu'on
fait quelque chose qu'ils essaient comme
devenu un peu dans les règles non
équipés du coup le mensonge est long
plus cette offre dans sa sortie
ce qu'on compare les pistes encore huit
centres toujours vrai décidé d'être le
plus honnête possible je pense
d'entrée de jules tes débuts
sexuellement que ce soit sur tous les
aspects et toutes appartenances avec eux
pour deux ans et demi plus tard un genre
de petites affaires dans le fond
finalement ça serait peut-être plus
souple comme et le jeu face à toutes les
fois fait deux ans que c'est comme ça
mais le président l'a pas fait enfin que
c'est gênant c'était comme un match à
succès mon fric je pensais le petit
tripp et quand je vais sur wii non non
non je vais faire plaisir tout avait
l'air d'être
way fac je pense que les schémas ouvre
des portes c'est quand y comprend que la
sexualité à sort d'une boîte la victime
donne cette permission le je pense
qu'ils étaient chez me viennent apporter
une autre perspective qui te donne la
permission d'explorer autre chose aussi
oui si c'est je pense que ça vient
soulager certaines personnes de savoir
que à mon dieu qui parce que le schéma
qui ne plus démontré dans la société
sexuelle et on voit soeur dans la porn
jeudi à touba pour d'actes vraiment
essentielle dans la porno le wef qui
met encore la csu part axé sur les
organes génitaux sur la domination aussi
sensuelle de dollars en plus pour femmes
diminue ses ministres ouais ouais karma
pis si c'est sûr que les femmes y avait
eu plus de femmes dans le sensuel mais
il ya aussi beaucoup d'hommes le
suspense il faut pas comme trop faire
d'associations non plus mais oui c'est
intéressant empressé d'aller travailler
je me rappelle j'avais un partenaire qui
était métamorphe puis je quelqu'un qui
communique quand même vraiment beaucoup
le dans mes rapports sexuels pour moi
cette importante et je veux dire en vol
avant la discussion parce que ce port
grec et au piment va être insatisfaits
dans ce rapport le pire j'ai pas de
filtre parce que je parle à tous les
jours de match
fait que word de tokyo cg j'applique
soit dans mes rapports sexuels qui sait
je vais en fait j'avais quelqu'un qui ne
savez comment c'est d'une certaine façon
puis avec le temps je m'étais ouverture
des choses que j'aime son dépit c'est
personnel c'était complètement moulé en
moi plus fréquent est vraiment bonne
j'ai dit bon skill des communications
chez soi que la personne était
complètement métamorphosé sa caisse
c'est devenu c'est pas facile pour cette
personne de s'habituer à moi de semoule
et à moi puis après ça j'ai compris
qu'il fallait que je fasse attention
parce que si le fun que ces personnes le
small un mois puis je trouve ça
extraordinaire les rapports sexuels que
je peux avoir avec cette personne le
mais faut faire attention parce que
cette personne n'ose elle a des besoins
puis vu qu'ils aient tout si on fait
juste une sorte
puisque métamorphe eux au petit trot met
à mort dont petite rousse moulée à à
l'autre puis finalement oublir ces prêts
d'oublier ses propres oui ça c'est un
des côtés négatifs des métamorphes c'est
d'être tellement vouloir plaire de
tellement vouloir se mouler à l'autre ça
peut être renforcée par l anxiété de
performance peut dire que c'est ton rôle
à toi de te rendre à penser sexuels
satisfaisants
que oui tu es quelqu'un peut
complètement s'oublier puis vont être
malheureux malheureuse dans sa sexualité
donc puis les métamorphes on se rendit
recueillant n'ont jamais assez c'est des
gens qui sont hyper autres les peuvent
via l'île pendant des heures ton à la
fois des écoutes d'abord parce qu'ils
peuvent tout faire qui ont envie de tout
faire comme sont jamais rassasiés sion
comme un peu ce sentiment le puits sont
ils sont un petit peu apport dans leur
sexualité hocine c'est bien qu'ils
soient absolument des départements
extrêmement
moi je souhaite à tout le monde de se
trouver un matamore ou du moins de bien
savoir exprimer son schéma j'ai une
question pour toi puis je sais pas c'est
une question que tu reçois des fois
mais moi avec avec
l'âge adulte puis le
la vie étant ce qu'elle est pis les
horaires qui sont serrés pile les
chutes il mettant quand j'arrive le soir
chez nous le jeu fatigué ma tante
inspire de désir ben pas une perte de
désir mais si je veux avoir des rapports
sexuels
faut que je fasse de la place pour que
j'ai pas le choix ça rit plus du seul
quand j'étais plus jeune ça arrivait de
succès mais ton qu'acheter début
vingtaine depuis que j'ai pas grand
chose d'autre à penser dans ma vie c'est
quand paris flotte dans un rapport
sexuel parce que parce que vous écoutiez
un film qui j'avoue que c'est ensemble
trois fois pas le faire nous en sommes
et on le sait ça m'arrivait avant sur
mettons laisser leur peau face deux
classes de trois heures une fois par
mois une fois par an si les deux taux
ont fait que tout le temps mais s'il
fallait
mais mettez ça avance ça m'arrive et
puis j'avais pas besoin de faire de la
place maintenant j'ai besoin de faire la
place puis c'est pas tout le temps
facile à à à ouvrir ton calendrier c'est
pas tout à fait facile de de faire cette
place le tipi je sais pas si c'est une
expérience qu'il yad'autres monde que
moi qui vieillit je sais pas si des
astuces ou des trucs que tu as pour ce
propos que c'est quand même un problème
parce que une fois que la place c'est
trop tard great d'istres d'alphone sauf
que des fois je vais comme montrer que
j'ai pas envie de par la place à manger
en face
c'est le moteur qui est
comme un vieux ski-doo comme cédric des
ordis comme un vieux ski-doo une fac
d'histoire est interprété ça vous aider
voici une moiteur à ces artistes
on rentrait dans les sujets du désir
sexuel qu'on parlait de ça et parce que
mais bon c'est mon accompagnement ça
fait genre
ok c'est mon accompagnement s'appelle
réponse sexuelle parce que je donne des
réponses sexuelle mais est la réponse
sexuelle c'est un concept en sexologie
qui englobe tout toutes les réponses et
physiques et psychologiques
de la sexualité dans le fond et est la
réponse excès c'est le graphique je peux
si on avait déjà parlé les graphiques et
ses désirs
je souhaitais excitation plateau orgasme
résolution ouais ouais j'ai déjà entendu
parler de soins on avait dit par une
allée je sais pas si tu es avec toi mais
je me rappelle avoir attendu par ce
possiblement
parce que c'est encore un
facteur excitation plateau orgasme
excitation c'est tout petit encore qui
se prépare à avoir un rapport sexuel il
faut comprendre que ce que j'ai nommé
extension plateau orgas pression c'est
que physiologique monnier et peu avant
le shiso les tuyaux warning une
agression sexuelle qui passe à travers
toutes ces étapes le quai c'est que
c'est logique c'est un réflexe du corps
c'est ton corps qui fonctionne comme si
quelqu'un y aura beaucoup de temps
piratage était
factice et pis c'est tout qu'est-ce-qui
direction lubrification et j'ai
tellement apprécié ton plateau c'est
pendant le rapport sexuel telle
extension qui monte qui descend qui
monte des sommes perçues à tâtons
orgasme et de la résolution la face des
résolutions et les plus longue chez les
hommes que chez les femmes et les hommes
surtout en gagnant en âge vont avoir
plus de besoin de plus de temps entre
les rapports sexuels par ce crime avant
qu'on puisse revenir à l'excitation le
corps a besoin d'une pause avec ses 6
physiologique puis avancée de la force
du désir qui fait partie de la réponse
sexuelle
des fois puis pourquoi je vous explique
tout ça allons le mais c'est que tu dis
karachi storti ça me tente c'est qu'il
peut interchanger l'excitation qu'il
désire dans la courbe donc une
estimation qui amène à l'excitation qui
érection lubrification et cetera donc
une fois que ton corps les autorités au
niveau réflexe top 10 et psychologique
de la partie puisque le
fait que beaucoup de gens qui sont comme
j'ai pas de désir mais une fois que ces
histoires étaient 70 puis je leur dis
bah oui parce que tu inverse les deux
files fax pour ça que des fois c'est
important et ça met du temps dans son
calendrier même si on n'a pas
nécessairement tout le temps envie bien
sûr faut que le concert soit le 20 mai
de dire c'est vrai que j'ai du plaisir
c'est vrai que j'ai envie de vivre ce
genre de sexualité le où j'ai des
rapports régulièrement avec mon
partenaire ou même en solo me dire je
sais qu'une fois que ça commence parce
que j'ai interchanger deux phases dans
la courbe de la réponse sexuelle
et le désosser super complexe mais ce
que j'ai goût de te demander aussi si m
puis c'était pour je réponds mais
quelqu'un qui a le même quelle somme
actuelle c'est dire ton niveau 7 saxons
sur dc ou
en ce moment il est proche de 10 le
hockey - dans mes relations actuelles
entre 8 et 10
hockey parce qu'il ya des gens qui pour
qu'il désavoue être que c'est correct me
répondit ce n'est pas ce que je vais
faire je le ferai la même
je vais répondre pour une autre relation
du où est-ce que c'était possible
seppi l'os était encore quasiment plus
dur de faire du temps puis de mettre de
l'avant des vétérans du problème
ça valait le niveau de cette saxons
venir aussi avoir une influence
puis souvent quand j'ai demandé t t au
sur disque une personne comme à 8 9 10
jugent comme ok parfait mais le thé la
personne est assis devant moi fait
définitivement il ya quelque chose qui
fonctionne
avec les choisit occupe ici tu peux
faire quelque chose amener des
ingrédients plus dans ton rapport sexuel
ça serait quoi ils vont me répondre des
choses que la personne ne fait pas enfin
que choisir à qui facturait rajouter
tout ce mais tu me dis que tu le fais
peut donc je te reposes la question à
dix et autosatisfaction plus souvent
c'est sur l'échelle de 10 plutôt de
satisfaction plus tu risques dans
l'ordre d'aisé le le contraire c'est pas
parce que tu peux te pose des actes a
pas de satisfaction le juste le dire
parce que les gens qu'on aime et
législatives libres désir
avec mémé s'est questionné par rapport à
son niveau de satisfaction je pense que
c'est toujours aussi m une bonne chose à
faire puis quand on dit mais j'ai la
satisfaction et le mais je suis fatigué
et je fais beaucoup de sport aussi je
sais tu le travail la job on est des
adultes le veut et on épie des
adolescents et qui travaillent à temps
partiel au cinéma guzzo la fin de
semaine qui on eu le temps d'être chez
lipp se coucher tard puis on a des
responsabilités on a des objectifs c'est
normal que ça vienne interférer dans la
vie sexuelle
donc les méta l'horaire de ce cce
maintenant c'est super au début le temps
nos premières dès maintenant votre ma
blonde c'est comme regarder les textes
en place et comme c'est un mercredi mais
ça se peut qu'on se couche à trois
heures du matin parce que c'est
mais je suis ça tu mettais au début vu
que c'est excitant belge en cas de
dérangement est utile je te manquer on
scrutera pas possible on faisait la
sexualité à 10 heures pas possibles
ouais mais jean maintenant c'est comme
si on l'a pas fait passer
aucune chance
costa riblon style de seacom à avec les
temps ont faut être capable de rentrer
dans la routine puis 6 pour entrer dans
une jarre de
doha
et puis les gens font souvent c'était
rare les deux comparé la fréquence des
rapports sexuels au début d'une relation
versus quand la vraie vie en barque tu
es complètement et aillent sur la
dopamine l'oxytocine la sérotonine
toutes les nuances et c'était à in fact
est pas fatigué le mailot a été shootée
à dopamine pas été vains c'est normal
d'avoir plus de désir au début il faut
jamais se fier à ce pour des mobiles au
début on faisait quatre par jour oubliez
solaire français quatre fois par jour le
car la vie en bacs parce qu'en plus au
début ça nous dérange pas d'être fatigué
pour aller travailler
vivre sur nos petits hormones du bonheur
puis ça me dérange pas nos amis de côté
mettre certaines responsabilités de côté
mais c'est pas m j'ai juste sustainable
de ses peurs ses beaux ville durable
donc il faut pas s'en vouloir pour ce
non plus je pense que les gens le
problème c'est qu'on se compare
énormément et c'est juste la fin de
sting dr godin envie qui cavalent phare
sur moi j'veux pas capable c'est juste
une croûte à cause de ça c'est quoi à
l'autre s'est fait arrêter de vous
comparer il ya personne qui sa sexualité
de la même façon plus envie de la vivre
la même façon dont plus de copies comme
tu disais tantôt se rend pas tout le
monde qui aime sous le faso pendant huit
ans non plus
je pense que le bs et trouver quelqu'un
qui est sensiblement le même niveau de
désir qu'elle est mais vert ans que toi
grosso modo maintenant vaincre et que
c'est que si c'est une fois par mois
mais qui les deux sont foule à l'aise
avec ce puis ça fait sale et
complètement
exacte mois et pis je pense que c'est
cette ici c'est vraiment d'arrêter de
cesse de se comparer
d'aller s'outiller c'est sur la
sexualité comprendre comment ils
fonctionnent les déserts si on a des
tonneaux dans le détail 9 je pense qu'on
avait peut-être parlé la dernière fois
dans un système d'inhibition sexuelle
est un système d'excitation sexuelle
puis c'est comme
une automobile teint frais et un
accélérateur
épisode 2 francs dans l'automobile
allait faire de toi aussi tu le frein
psychologique ticket mettons ça prend
trop de temps faculty trains neufs parce
que ça me prend trop de temps avec les
par
exemple people freins qui est tout les
facteurs externes style mettons les
mauvaises odeurs
et à les accélérer
j'ai pas de pitié pour ces messieurs
non mais j'ai pigé la performance ils
n'ont cessé comme un tout petit
diffuseur attachant mais ouais j'ai
leicher d'accès mais c'est juste je dis
je vous prends ta douche le temps
viendra mettez je veux juste finir ce
que je suis
les odeurs corporelles du corps même
écart pour aimer
jusqu'à une certaine limite c'est ce
qu'ont compris voilà paquet ceci étant
dit je disais quoi exactement ah oui sur
les systèmes croyais au facteur est un
homme qui s car et c'est que des gens il
ya des gens qui vont avoir c'est comme
dans un autre seul frein sur
l'accélérateur puis sur le lait les
offres les fringues toronto à table
avant ce beau nul part et où ça donne
des petits coups peace & poor's peuple n
a fait qu il faut que je trouve un moyen
de lever le pied sur le frein pour
pouvoir mettre le pied sur
l'accélérateur puis pour faire ça il
faut que tu trouves tu étais un oeuf
qu'il faut que je trouve des terrains
des gens qui ne comprennent pas quelles
sont leurs tours 9
puisque ça fait en sorte que ça je suis
complètement le désirent parce que son
offre ils savent pas pourquoi ils
pensent qu'ils sont brisés qui ont peu
de désir qui leur bain à force d'essayer
de comprendre les mauvaises odeurs moi
car j'ai une liste de tâches à faire que
j'ai pas passer à travers et quand il
passé onze ans le sort de l'énergie
donc il faut créer des contextes sexuels
qui sont adéquats pour avoir des
rapports sexuels plus c'est compliqué
aux ouailles mais arrêtez de penser que
ça tombe du ciel je comprends que c'est
ce qu'on voit le d'un film lucky dans le
porno le monde qui ont juste envie de se
dévorer
posso la vie la vraie vie c'est comme
commencer à dire je brûle il faut jamais
dans mon oreille à présent ça se passe
peu puis ce n'est pas comme au début
c'est ça la vraie vie active je pense
que les gens veulent avoir des
sexualités extraordinaire en une
mi-temps peu d'efforts pour en avoir un
c'est courir un marathon le stif et du
cou jusqu'aux t'entraînes tu te lèves le
matin de bonne heure sup d'aliments bien
tu prends des suppléments de tivaouane
c'est que c'est extraordinaire renseigne
toi sur le sujet va chercher des outils
communiquent davantage découvre doit
davantage
fac tu veux plus de désir trouve titre
entre terre-neuve qu'un exemple c'est ce
que je peux donner en fer qui est
vraiment simple ça serait de dire tu
prends
tu écris ton père rapports sexuels le
phare attention personnes qui ont vécu
des traumatismes des événements un petit
peu plus négatifs
bien respecté sa limite dans cet
exercice le net tu prends ton père
rapports sexuels c'est vraiment l'écrit
avec le plus de détails possibles genre
qu'est ce que tu portais cette journée
là comme un kit santé c'était qu'il
autres personnes comme qu'est-ce qu'a
santé qu'est ce que le lieu était rapide
tu fais là même le même exercice pour
ton meilleur rapport sexuel avis sur les
compacts sur gamme qu'est-ce qui
différencie l'un l'autre et digard
décerné à 69,60 theron pilote peut créer
un contexte sexuel qui fait que les
étoiles sa ligne pour qu était tout un
rapport sexuel puis dire à chaque fois
on enlève et un oeuf ouais j'ai un vague
souvenir je pense que je pense que
peut-être on avait parlé avec les
chorales pis y'a pas que jamais
questionnaire que tu peux faire avec
genre
une liste de trine 9 d'être une
potentielle plus à votre com voir un peu
c'est quoi titrée neuf l'étaient parce
qu'elle est pour kim et on le fait pas
avoir pris sa douche il ne peut pas
aller faire le sexe pour d'autres comme
un fouet
et oui et messages oui j'ai un livret
qui s'appelle come as you are des
milliers nago ce qui désole pour les
et il y aura questionnaire dans son
livre sinon dans mon accompagnement sur
un mois complet sur le désert sexuel ou
skate plein plein plein
d'exercices que tu peux faire petit peu
habituel pour comprendre on désire aussi
pile l'alimenter
mais dans le livre il ya aussi des airs
des exercices que tu peux faire sinon ça
se trouve le en ligne aux délices de 39
le son sort s'il cela permet de mieux
comprendre aussi
pourquoi met-on ta partenaire ou tonton
partenaires
[Musique]
j'imagine que
leur faut que je sois quand même craint
qu'il m'aimait ton après chaque sans
nécessairement l'écrire dans un journal
thê après chaque relation sexuelle si tu
te fais toi même un genre de deux check
list mental de caisse qui viennent se
passait puis mettons c'était comment
pour toi pis c est pourquoi est-ce que
ce téléphone qui est aimé ton puis que
la presse a deux fils de relation avec
leur relation à mener maintenant que ce
soit - mais que c'était mon iphone pour
la main quand même été capable de
vraiment bien les cerner j'imagine
qu'ils sont on avait parlé dans le
dernier podcast du pilotage mois puis je
pense que tu avais dit que c'est avec ta
copine
oui c'est totalement important puis ça
alimente puis tout avait dit à cette ton
tableau 1
[Musique]
mais à chaque fois on fait mme siby
crime sexuel par
deux matches trop c'est de faire c'est
ce qu'est ce que tu as l'impression que
ça alimente ta sexualité positivement
oui absolument
mais oui c'est sûr c'est soro puis des
fois c'est comme les foyers tu penses
que je connais l'autre mais il peut
avoir encore des surprises un hôpital de
l'enfant et qui se se mord date ce
défaut si ça dépend des jours n'est
certes pas des contacts souci c'est que
aussi qu' il faut commencer à prendre
des journées qui
que ma blonde a même resto qui se soit
vraiment toujours justement très sensuel
c'est super en douceur avec toute
l'énergie accumulée
non mais des fois des remous de
l'internaute boucle c'est juste des
fausses idées et parler de ce mets mais
oui c'est sûr que ça c'est sûr que ça
alimente ça fait qu'on tombe pas dans
des
dents les patterns dans des bottines ou
dans des genres de devic on s'en parle
pas oublié quelque chose que comme pas
été fameux pour un des deux mais l'on ne
pas parler vaincu les ovoproduits simple
on peut tomber lénine d'ordre exiger le
cas ci dessous est en fait d'en parler à
chaque fois ça fait qu'il ya pas de
mauvais plis mettons que ce crime
exactement puis j'ai l'impression qu'on
a plus de facilité à le faire quand
c'est plaisant ouais mais bon ça c'est
bon c'est bon ça pique à ses com puis-je
comment tu dis à quelqu'un qui est à moi
mais ce comment ça s'est passé là ta g
avec l'autre mais je pense que c'est un
mal nécessaire pour tout le monde le
sait comme on le dit en tous ces jeunes
à le faire quelque chose que l'autre
mpoc tous ses potes ses proches jeudi
génère métissé comme c'est plate pour le
front noah était là pour avoir utilisé
pour partager quelque chose fac et pis
moi je le répète tout le temps là jeudi
et s'est maintenue
partager un moment avec quelqu'un en
silence ouais je te papa paraît la plus
petite botha le nez comme parle peu et
rabbit vittavi aime ça venait pas de se
passer ceci oui moi pour normaliser ce
nom tu veux en parler de vue communiqué
c'est tellement ça rentre ça tellement
enrichissante et puis en plus des séries
de rieter que ce serait oui mais c'est
fou tu sais moi je le vois le team où
j'y suis pas quelqu'un qui mal à l'aise
de parler de dieu soit avec
sur un podcast du permis dizaines de
milliers personnes seraient pas de casse
tout et avec des amis quoi que ce soit
métier
j'ai plusieurs les coupes d'amity qui
est
qui disent quand même dont on n'a pas
pas vraiment pi4 tu l'auras parle aussi
de 1,2 à 1 c'est comme ça
le sens mal à l'aise le 10 encaissés peu
un sujet qui sont confortables à l'eiti
pied c'est dommage ne pareil parce que
c'est
une partie d'un coup bien sûr mettons ce
pas sexualité souvent
ça fait partie d'un couple atypique mais
c'est encore super commence espèce de
malaise le tabou le pij a pris pas mal
de coups de coupes qui jeu comme s'il
était que ça se passe on n'en parle plus
puis amman et ça va se passer et puis
elle serait en réalité parallèle dit que
mon père se pose à nouveau on n'est pas
inspiré c'est ce que m'avait jamais
christine sioui c'est ça c'est
complètement le reflet du manque
d'éducation oui on en parle peu on n'est
pas habituée n'en parlez donc pourquoi
on appellerait plus quand on le fait
ouais c'est juste normal de ne pas en
parler puis pourtant tout une sexualité
tonnes sexualité j'ai une sexualité tout
le monde qui nous écoutent en une
je commence donc à avoir une
incompréhension par rapport au fait
qu'on n'est pas capable d'en parler
peut-être parce que c'est parce que je
baigne trop dedans parce que c'est mon
quotidien mais c'est tellement
libérateur
puis encore une fois on est programmé
pour le plaisir on est programmé pour un
message pour qu'on fait c'est finalement
si c'est pas pour combler une pulsion
combler un désir avoir du plaisir
faites moi c'est essentiel il faut que
la communication soit le standard j'ai
vraiment l'impression que c'est dans
l'éducation type qui mettons machine où
on ne parlait jamais de sexualité le
genre pas si jamais venu sur le sujet le
dream qui inversement mettons le voit
parce que on n'en parle plus grâce à des
personnes comme toi grâce à wes etc sera
le même temps où est-ce que c'est plus
dans la culture d'en entendre parler
témoin juste ma ma soral des discussions
pied avec ses enfants qui sont encore
jules dethier par rapport à la sexualité
puis s'est dernièrement il ya eu une
c2c petit kiki et
qui portait comme 30 minutes survie des
lions comme un bidet puis campagne en
deux minutes en un sens lançant le bidet
dans l'anus puis ou sur la nuit puisque
dans l'anus mai puis la discussion
c'était page aurait été passé puis
jallet on en parle plus on ignore ce qui
se passe et c'est comme cela ça se peut
que ce soit l'iphone mais comme et cette
farce au nom des idées moment propice à
cela n'entache en pitié déjà ce
j'imagine que si kanté cid c'est pas
genre votre cash et puis j'aurais parlé
de masturber ce genre tu bartoli porte
plutôt comme un super nerveux de fer
poignet puis j'imagine que ça va aider à
démocratiser les conversations tournent
la sexualité comme cette étape à la
maison tu arrives à l'école on n'en
parle pas vraiment apporté ma mère pis
ses soeurs c'est fou quand même de
penser qu'avant qu'il y avait plus de
podcasts de page comme latine c'était
comme tout le monde dit se mêler tout le
monde se demande s'ils sont normales qui
demandent cette bande c quoi
l'expérience des autres comment ça se
passe et du sommet qui n'ont pas de
réponse pour ce intervient au début
c'est comme
ça je pense là trépy les comme l'intérêt
pour ce c'est comme enfin on peut
écouter du monde normal ou des
professionnels n'en parlait puisse
rendre compte quelqu'un qu'ils soient
sociaux ça existe c'est normal
supporteurs allemands s'est enfin en
fait ouais et puis si tu parlais de ce
podcast et sexe oral
c'est tellement c'est incroyable qu'une
personne comme lisanne nadeau qui est
une tribune immense avec la visibilité
qu'elle est qu'on soit capable dans ces
discussions le puits le monde capote sur
ce mode cassent le jeu d essayer ce
n'est qu'un début le puits les gens
aiment ce autant parce que pie ix est
parce qu il ya personne qui parle de ces
choses là un pilot enfin tu entends des
gens dire et moi je pense comme ceux
puis je fonctionne comme ce puits hawaii
tout fonctionne même qui sont
différentes pistes challenge à travers
la fin de leur façon de vivre la
sexualité pis il ya comme la place pour
qui tout le monde peut se reconnaître
puis ça ça valide sa normalise puis les
gens ont vraiment besoin de ce fait les
jambes il y en a qui ont besoin de faire
de la consultation dans le noir mais
comme j'aime enseigner tantôt c'est
l'éducation qui va amener la
transformation juste d'être renseigné
souvient le temps lui est un pote sur
les épaules par rapport à des choses que
tu peux penser que ton corps était pas
normal et s y était ce or on veut
tellement s'émanciper à travers
l'éducation puis à travers ces
discussions le puis ça commence quand et
j'aime
vraiment cette agression le pit et
j'avais j'ai fait une entrevue cette
semaine puis on parlait justement de
l'utilisation de deux surnoms le pour
nommer les organes génitaux le genre
zizi oui
gresh plus kyo s'est pas
fait mais juste ce ca perpétue le tabou
ouais mais j'ai un prénom ah ouais c'est
vraiment en fait c'est
vrai je me je me posais cette question
là en plus dernièrement parce que
pour une raison x ou y va falloir que je
parle de ma graines
dans un autre contexte difficile de
trouver une façon genre qu'est le mot je
vais utiliser pour pouvoir parler plus
et comme je t'ai même mal à l'aise avec
le mot péniche à dire le mot péniche
déconne pas sur celles de bonbons mais
en même temps je te dirai ma que c'est
à cause de mon avril
le genre
je vais aller mettre la petite crème sur
le pénis à cuba où je rêvais fait quoi
non
je pendant longtemps c'est comment dire
qu'elle dit souvent qu'à peut-être plus
jamais
que ça tu as quatre points à l'arrêté de
l'elysée au moment où je commence à
former des mémoires
passé trois ans la scala
sfr
avec 120 caméras mais non b puis je dire
un poumon c'est un poumon suite à un
coup de rein star unités mais on est
copie même même mois le mot vulve
jolie au naturel ça met tout seul
maintenant c'est à nous c'est dit c'est
dit il des fois pour moi de même le
désir d'acheter les capsules vidéo qui
m'aime moi le jeu comme ta bulle
je sais on va y aller parce que c'est
seulement au pcc on est vraiment puis
inconsciemment ce que ça fait c'est ça
c'est ça perpétuent des tabous et il ya
un tabou qui persistent pions on dispose
de réserves et puis après ça comment
avoir des conversations sur ce qui te
fait plaisir dans ce soir puis j'ai pété
les vidéos sur le secteur qui est
récemment c'est ça c'est ça si répandu
des cheveux oui mais en fait j'ai
demandé dans une vidéo ses côtés et en
plus grands auteurs 9 sexuelle de jeter
une trâlée de réponse le lay avait du
monde ce à commenter ça commençait à
commenter puis il y avait du monde qui
parle et puis pas problème j'ai fait le
même exercice pour layton les
niaiseries
que j'ai reçue est il prendre un bain
dans le pepto bismol en se coupant une
oreille et des conneries
on n'est pas capable d'assumer qu'on a
du plaisir dans cette passe le devis
puis d'un autre côté on se vante de nos
exploits puis l'on se compare avec les
exploits des autres qui ont l'air des
meilleures cliniques puis mais
réellement n'est pas capable si si c'est
dur d'être si loin devant l'autre peas
et ça ça me fait vraiment plaisir et ça
ça m'excite quand même c'est sûr oui
mais en même temps ce métier veut avoir
une sexualité épanouie avec ton ta
partenaire me semble que c'est plus
facile du dit qu'est ce qu'ils font
qu'est-ce-qui paul face il faudra
forcément positif ou du moins moi je
pense c'est plus efficace aussi des et
quand tu y fais ce que j'aime vraiment
ce plus qui s'est passé ce fait décidé
d'amener le
la direction voir les trucs son iphone
plutôt que de dire qu'est ce qui pour le
fun et oui prologue de fall fois pareil
ces séjours de se faire reprocher des
choses qui en plus dans un espace où s'y
tient peut-être un peu responsable c'est
du plaisir que tu offres à l'autre
personne parler de faire reproche x pour
ce que tu es en train de faire c'est
toujours difficile à recevoir
fake
renforcement positif je pense que c'est
vraiment la chose à faire pitt avant
déduction d'amblie
scandaient que l'on devrait quasiment on
devrait en parler d'un sexuelle rôle
c'est comment tu vois surtout c'est que
l'éducation je savais qu'elles sont 5
comme cisco l'éducation que j'ai reçue à
ben mosbah on n'en parlait pas la maison
tu es tu vraiment parler dit mais ce que
tu verras ce qu'ont bien des
conversations sur le sujet oui non puis
on est capable de voir ce qu'on va être
capable d'explorer avec l'eau personnes
dans l'assaut sur toi avec ton
fréquentation de dessus et vous parler
avant que ça se passe non pas avant que
ça se passe après oui le barman ça se
passe
c'est comme un coup de chance mais bon
c'est comme un genre ouais mais aussi
peut-être que
je pose une question de l'effet chabrol
puis je te pose je pose la question est
ce que est ce que les chinois mettons
peuvent aussi quand même à être
indiquée par la personnalité la personne
parce que mettons c'est arrivé mettons
ces arrivées on a eu une relation
sexuelle plus j'ai fait acquis
de ce même schéma mais en même temps je
t'ai pas surpris que ce soit le même
schéma parce que il y avait beaucoup
d'affaires qui qui s'alignaient dans
comme nos personnalités puis comment on
était par rapport à x ou y informatif et
que des poches darqroom ça marche bien
ça allait de soi un peu le trouble et
sempé simple il ya des vocabulaires du
vocabulaire qu'on va utiliser selon nos
différents schémas ça peut être même ta
façon ton attitude ta façon de tvi
donc oui il ya des indicateurs chez
quand même bonne pour lire les schémas 3
c'est important butin mais maintenant tu
regardes qu'un petit jard web va voir
comment tu fonctionnes a tenté pas mal
plus je pense que tu es dans ce schéma
ouais ouais c'est ça je me trompe
rarement je suppose une coupe des
questions le pij m comme tu es ce que
nous sommes et j'ai peu j'ai passé des
détails sur vous mais le fait que tu en
parles avec tu peux c'est vraiment du
gros n'importe quoi charensac le fait
que tu en parles tu étais c'était cette
ouverture le et
tu dois être dans le flou est proche du
sensuel ci doit être proche de censure
pas mal certaines et peut-être que je me
trompe je t'aiderai sensuel et sexuel
-
quand une grande ouverture aussi parce
que je me rappelle qu'on avait parlé de
prostate la dernière fois
absolument pitoyable on va composer à
écouter ovine farc la wii et quoi
en cours afin qu'ils je pense qu'on
avait parlé de tirs dans les premiers
quatre minutes du pas de calais jacques
et moi ma blonde avait fait une petite
commande
de boîte blog club décide pour toi
mais finalement les bottes loi qui ont
servi pour toi at il pas le plus gros
deal
un an plus tôt et avait un petit côté
kings qui veulent ben ouais
essentielle dans le fond kinki ça c'est
un
basket landes est quelqu'un qui aime
explorer des affaires de carla d'avoir
une certaine douceur dans qu'est ce que
tu fais métier ces foules du jugement
lequel je lance en ce moment parce qu'on
n'a pas eu assez de conversation pour
que chacun y déceler moi je pense qu'il
faut que je travaille sur badoo ça ok ok
je pense que je suis relativement
en mode de
jeu trauma en mode performance quand
même
être écrits des scripts le descriptif ex
ump
d'effectivement petit côté kinky mais je
pense qu'ils aient moins je pense qu'il
faut que je travaille ma tout ça je
pense que je plus sexuel que sensuelle
mais
faudrait que j'atteigne les métamorphes
pour justement kaki et ben moi je pense
que ça manque pas beaucoup pour
atteindre le métamorphose
mais avec l'ouverture qu'à te vois je
pense des proches de m a morflé pas de
jeu
oui c'est moi jdit sexuelle en suède
pays qui peut-être parce qu énergie que
tu as peut-être jamais essayé ce si je
ne sais pas mais ouailles potec étaient
métamorphe mais que j'étais mort
continue art et créer des scripts que tu
te laisses pas vraiment à toi même dans
ta sexualité
c'est tout aurait tué les gardes d'être
laissée aller maintenant
parce qu'on a mis sur la glace fantômes
et à eau des quinconces nous en fait il
ya plus haut de gamme en dallas où
est-ce qu'ils vont attaquer puis il y
avait du monde est capable de se laisser
aller chrismaëlle ont le constater mais
moi je moi j'étais 0 le bain c'était
quand même rendu temps quand même versé
une petite larme fact it quand même
synthétique quand même une ouverture que
ça touche paraguay mais dois-je mais
comme tu excelles loin pas être dans la
sexualité
mais ouais mais c'était vraiment un
organe n'était pas juste
un organe hockey
et la semaine prochaine je m'en viens
dans une retraite de méditation
s'appelle vipassana je sais pas si ça
fait déjà entendu parler savamment
troisième fois que j'y vais ça c'est
sept jours ce cd studio du journal cela
c'est la troisième fois qu'il faut faire
c'est essayer mettons longue journée de
méditation un terminal wii
se lève à 4 heures du matin tu couches
en avoir le soir la danse environ une
dizaine d'heures de méditation dans type
aux séries mais j'espère être de plein
droit de lire et apprendre à décrire
téléphone par les labos c'est vraiment
le silence n'opte importe de faire des
tacles dit si tu es dans ta bulle du
registre du minable tu fais ça oui
si le troupeau tout fait oui pilage
l'après angle parce que je suis dans une
tornade en ce moment avec mon entreprise
ce pied je sais pas si je vais être
capable de rester les jo pas ce qu'est
ce ce cadeau
est ce que mse gens curieux oui tous des
modèles hybrides en quand elle a beau me
tend à
ouvrir vous retrouverez il ya des
journées le pied on est en silence mais
on a des halles de méditation dans le
fond qui étaient assistés des voisins de
des méditations matelote les matelotes
méditation de thaïs inquiète a signé
avec dépendant du jour à côté des mêmes
personnes qui tu viens tellement
sensible à ton environnement que tu sais
quand l'autre à côté de toi fils pas
cette journée test était bien envoyé
l'homme l'encouragement et énergétique
ça ça va se parler
on brise le silence une journée avant de
sortir du centre parce qu'elle est faux
comme revenir tranquillement
les caves à saluer la journée numéro
cercle je te voyais le tt pas dedans
pantoute tipi le survient le lendemain
pilules sont assis sur leurs mcs leurs
quatre heures du matin comme hier les
bollingers petit asseoir à côté le petit
et dale moi je me rappelle s'est élevé à
4 heures du matin c'est inhumain et la
limite était le scan des clous comme un
symbole puis je me rappelle à chacun aux
caisses les faits sont là le gie bien
pigé le faire pendant deux ans que plus
j'arrive et pillé telle pièce créée
qu'en l'espèce depuis il me disait la
même chose quand je voyais vous étiez là
on était comme trop sur la lune qui est
ce que ça va donner que la fille tess a
fait en même temps moi on avait la même
aujourd'hui
c'était sa grande expérience incroyable
qui cache charrie la première fois
j'étais en pleine d'amour
piquante et la boîte à prangins observer
les sensations dans ton corps et à ne
pas leur donner des deux
caractéristiques ou d'importance ou de
valeur quelconque sanction observe qui
c'est vrai tique quand est franche et
puis quand tu es ma tante est en amour
le petit but de l'excitation quitté
fâché si les mêmes même mêmes sensations
corporelles
quand il est des composites show
attaquant qui peut vite c'était ta
respiration qui quissac et s'accélère
qu'elles soient fâchés qui soit comme
excité c'est les mêmes choses c'est
juste notre cerveau qui donne des
caractéristiques différentes à ce qu'on
ressent fait là bas tu apprends observer
et c'est super difficile parce que
j'étais vraiment blessé le staff et je
pense à fait comme cinq ans de cela ma
première fois 4
je suis venu le thème en forget après la
technique parce que j'étais comme je
peux pour sentir d'un mot finalement si
je peux poèmes c'est là que j'ai appris
que l'amour c'est pas de la passion mais
c'est bien de la compassion
c'est tellement différent comme comme
comme sentiment qu'ils aiment
je me suis vraiment prêter au jeu qui je
vais vraiment bien fait ma mamie dix
jours puis à la 8e journée tout ça pour
vous
karlsson journée facile puis j'ai
vraiment réussi assez quand on dit
laisse monter ta pensée pilès la passe
et je maîtrise à fond la caisse on était
trois heures dans la journée trois fois
une heure où tu t'assois piteux palois
de bouger face à big apple demande à
quelle porte bouche potes sur yes
l'observent la sensation savoir but à
voir partir d'avoir vita va partir dit
la juge pote tu fais des scan corporel
qui jeta dans un scan corporel pleut ça
allait bien puis j'ai j'ai eu un orgasme
énergétique puis je savais pas que ça
existait je ne savais pas que j'allais
vivre ce j'avais aucune idée de ce que
je m'en allais vivre quand je rentrais
la bbc comme
je peux même pas quoi que je dise où
j'ai vécu un orgasme énergie de cycle
c'est comme ton corps au complet vibre
spots et organes génitaux c'est juste
comme un sentiment de jeu c'est pas
tellement en pleine conscience avec
d'étaiement connecter avec
l'environnement l'énergie autour de toi
que c'est comme ça vibre
gestion seconde fois que j'y crois
ça c'est quelque chose de réussi à
garder maintenant dans ta vie a présenté
pratiquement où c'était un one shot
arriver là c'était comme si wade les
l'orgasme énergétique et j'essaie quand
même rendre et je ne veux pas l'amener
dans les rapports sexuels mais
maintenant que j'ai dans une méditation
et je sais comment faire bouger
l'énergie dans mon corps mais c'est dans
ma tête je vais juste par des flots
corporelle je sais comment me rendre
mais il faut que je sois prédisposés il
faut qu'un faux pas comment t'es tu as
soit trop occupés il faut passer ce fait
pas juste à recevoir l'appui après une
heure l'orgasme énergétique ça m'a pris
huit jours ça faisait 80 heures de
méditation que je fais il non stop a pas
parlé à personne car aucune distraction
parce que les journées sont plus en plus
l'on s'éloigne du sujet de la sexualité
mais l'espagnol est ce que les journées
sont plus en plus en plus difficile va
m'amener de plus en plus face ça prend
de plus en plus
ces interminables c'est à chaque seconde
de ma vie que je la veux j'ai envie de
m'en aller je me demande pourquoi je le
puis je me rappel après empêche d'aller
voir rêve tu te dois poser une question
le midi j'étais allé voir mon enseignant
qui avait dit il ya un moment où ça va
est à passer plus vite comme
non non
notre ami film berne est allé en
thaïlande puis fit un genre de 28 jours
dans une affaire d'hommes à qui il dit
lui sont de son expérience maintenant
après au 14e jour il ya eu comme un
brave dame ultime où et comme si mis à
pleurer ce genre incontrôlable le mans
pendant la journée au complet puis une
fois qui a passé ses 14 jours le mettons
que la journée vraiment vraiment
complètement une scène était derrière
lui il disait être capable de
s'installer maintenant dans sa chambre
puis là il se disait sur le sol puis
tire d'érable de devoir comme s'ils
étaient en coin la pièce puis ce voyage
même puis dix après cela les jus ce que
jusqu'à fin le faire comme passer les
jours passent et janvier ça allait parce
que au début on est tellement peu
habitué des justes c'est sûr que ce
combat contre la programmation qui a
étudié yves le c'est intuitif pour nous
de faire ouais bien qu'on est juste cinq
ans quant à eux des moments qu'ont connu
juste ce
qu'ils on
n'est jamais confronté à une joueuse
comme avec nous mêmes peut rien faire
l'équipe de dopamine pic en jeu la belge
tout empreint de jeumont je vends mon
ses marges et je tenterai le chercher
mais je lis pas parce qu'il donne à
l'entrée c'est horrible comment qu'on
est comme adéquat c'est fou hein pour
rien pauvre et c'est à chaque fois puis
je dois le faire je vais chercher mon
téléphone j'ai senti que ça va m'arriver
je vois virus gg parle de porto fait
cette fois lotus et là c'est la plus
grande dépendance collective qu'on a
piqué on s'en rend même pas compte mais
ouais on est tous addict c'est la plus
grosse merde à la technologie c'est fou
c'est moi et moi sim soit un voyage qui
est comme je me donne une règle comme
petit 1,6 après une couple de jours un
genre comme philippe bas mais après 4
passes et couples d'aujourd'hui c'est
comme je suis tombé depuis le temps il
dans la perception du tendre et le temps
passe comme plus lentement mais d'une
bonne manière à ce que tu mens comme tu
vis plus toutes les moments plutôt que
d'égaler torrentielles tu peux le
regarder tannins présents lors des cinq
minutes le regard des traminots
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose mais
justement j'imagine qu'ils en sortant
d'une en faire de même
toutes ces addictions le que te paul
chouette de très fortes et pas mal plus
maintenant quand tu prends ton c'est lui
en sortant de l'ue j'imagine qu'ils
aient le thé consciente potentiel c'est
pô juste une espèce d'affaires j'essaie
de le garder le plus longtemps possible
ce feeling nous sommes tombés dans ce
cas manège majine que ça ça ce disciple
que tu retournes troisième fois non mais
j'y retourne parce que je suis vraiment
dans un tourbillon en ce moment et avec
le travail qui je suis sollicité
constamment puis changer ce que j'ai
besoin de me déposer je le ferai pas si
j'allais au costa rica pendant l'hiver
pour essayer de faire ce dont j'ai
toujours pas quitté la baule fasquel je
me suis ok j'y vais je dis je je les
fais je sais pas si je vais être capable
je me souhaite parce que oui quand tu
sors de le faire les choses tellement
plus consciemment une première fois j'ai
fait un master à boston au massachusetts
de pièges à vingt six heures de route à
faire puis josé même permettre la radio
le temps oui tellement j'avais besoin de
200 stimuli je savais qu'en brise
décelant cela l'avant-dernière journée
là c'est comme toi dont on veut se
cacher dans nos chambres ont été
commandés par seconde c'est ce qui
semblait si
le s'est rendu au monde il faut par
exemple était comme un loup et le 6ème
sortir dans les 10 jours avec toi même
qui fait que des gens qui vont écouter
surface est vraiment spécial mais non
dans le fond c'est une tête avec moi
même que je me refais un
hacker tout ça pour dire que les
orgasmes et énergétique j'en ai vécu un
je sais c'est quoi je dis je m'attendais
pas à ce problème ans qui était à audi
s'attendait pas à ça non plus non je
pense a surpris tout le monde
ça
fait un moment que marquer les esprits
le cas marque phare commence et il a
commencé ce jour l'épisode caps
est ok qui se passe de quoi ses missions
le temps mais toute la scène dans le
théâtre qui sont assis à terre deux par
deux qui met tant mieux parce qu
il ya des gens qui ont normalisé leurs
expériences en voyant ce qu'il peut et
demande qu'ils en parlent peu qu'ils
vivent ce genre de regard soigneusement
ils ont trouvé vraiment space d'avancé
aujourd'hui le sais
mais je devais je l'aimé pas chercher
ça se développe facquet c'est ce qui
pose ses fables dans bien des gens qui
vont dire peut-être que peut-être que
c'est moi c'est vrai qu'à des classes
approche vite je me sens invite même
acte et je suis très sensible aux
énergies des autres
donc
c'est possible tout est possible on a
parlé rapidement trop tôt de plaisir
prostituées j'ai vu que
tu titre mettons les lécher mode
anéantie cet atelier conférence sur les
schémas qui avait plusieurs sujets dans
le feutre sur le sectionnant je pense
mais hélas qui s'en vient
mais bon j'étais curieux de savoir
qu'est ce qu'il y avait un mouton à dire
oui mais
m beaucoup de choses est sa ville comme
c'est l'engagement le sur instagram et
il voit le cahier les sujets ils sont en
fait qu'une curiosité hier se met ses
quatre balles de set canal c'est comme
ça ah ouais mais mais juste sexe oral ou
si je pense l'épisode sur la nappe je
pense qu'encore à ce jour 6 1 il est
plus écouté cette fois de plus écoutés
et rossi compagnie avait soldats tous
leurs blogs après cet épisode la série
comme d'accueil de la cure juste mais
j'imagine c'est le tabou aussi commander
le déboute ex teint et oui et puis tout
le monde veut savoir comme youtube
vraiment du plaisir à cet endroit le
parce que là on voit ça dans la porno
buzz au fac puis il ya beaucoup de
plaisir qui se développe encore une fois
aurier a su avoir une sexuelle
extraordinaire prend le temps de
terribles aurait prend le temps de
découvrir ton plaisir anal prend le
temps dans la ruhr des orgasmes
énergétique ça m'a pris 8 180 heures de
méditation cefac ça arrive repos tu
t'assois peux tu penses que tu ressens
des affaires parce que ça prend foutu de
l'essai était fac l'anus le rectum c'est
un endroit où il ya des milliers de
terminaisons nerveuses
pourquoi peut avoir du plaisir en
activant ses terminaisons nerveuses
donc il ya un très très grand potentiel
puis je me rappelle gérard prof à l'uni
qui avait dit dans un court et
peu importe même au niveau du vagin
parce que le vagin
pertinent le vagin et com ses paris en
en trois parties c'est vraiment le
premier tiers du vagin qu'il ressent
réellement le plaisir puis le deux tiers
qui suivent plus ressentir comme la
propension puis la douleur
mais qui peut le travailler puis c'est
ce que joannie a fait un travail le
point g découvrez votre point j'étais en
vous et moi le point g existe paul qui
n'existe pas c'est prouvé il ya peu de
points dans le vagin de chercher chez
vous puis de chercher ton point il y en
a pour référence à la personne d'andy
goode oui c'est que tu stimule
indirectement le clitoris la pause de
chaque côté de l'entrée du vagin donc
pour ceux que le premier tiers du vagin
c'est la partie sensible puis il faut
prendre le temps de cl sa trousse le
sait seule essayer d etat plein
d'idées ce point d'étape avant qui fait
que tu ressens plus qu'intimes hull
c'est le fait que tu t'arrêtes pour
prendre un moment avec toi conscience
aussi exactement cccc du tantrisme sa
trousse le bon sens talent c'est ton
verre de vin c'est l'odeur du papier
secteur chandelle c'est tombé chaussée
et son hip hop cc fac ça se développe
ses sensations le tout comme le plaisir
anal pour se développer
des terminaisons nerveuses donc du
potentiel pour avoir du plaisir
c'est en inspectant douleur plaisir le
oui ça peut faire mal les numéros et
voilà la ligne
mais qui a déjà qu'il ya trois ans à
face au mal puisqu'il faut vraiment être
clair là dessus c'est ça vous fait mal
ton corps envoie un signal
il
faut y aller
tu veux pas comme street
sans préparation sans lubrification
paiement pythie
illusoire de penser que ça va être
plaisant c'est ça il ya des étapes le
tpiy que ça soit de commencer à stimuler
sait déjà qui on doit ça les dérange
commence avec les jointures de ta main
juste passé juste s'habituer à recevoir
une stimulation au niveau de l'anus
parce qu'ils étaient pas habitués à
recevoir une stimulation que c'était
cinq ans tu vois la cl mais de se faire
toucher à 100 drôle c'est que
je ressens la halle aux sports c'est
différent comme fac tu veux juste
s'habituer ton corps à ces sensations
l'autre commence par l'extérieur
quelquefois une fois que tu es habitué à
ce le tu peux commencer à explorer à
l'intérieur mais les gens ils veulent
que tu es allé avec la pénétration
ça prend du temps
faute habite encore puis comme et comme
il est ce que mettons la partie interne
du clitoris et stimuler pas dissimulé
par le sexe anal ou si c'est pas
vraiment l'équité les frais si c'est
tout relié terre la fin de la journée
c'est comme si ton plancher pelvien taux
plancher pelvien c'est lui qui est
activé lors de l'orgasme donc c'est sûr
qu'il ya des stimulations qui vont peser
sur ta veste y apprécier la pièce la
vessie paille sur le clitoris et cetera
donc oui c'est possible d'avoir un
orgasme haut niveau en ahl
il ya plusieurs points d'orgasme aussi
dans le corps humain encore une fois je
les mentionnaient tantôt ses projets ses
organes génitaux qui donne des orgas
donc pas juste le clitoris juillet
responsable de l'orgasme et de l'orgasme
mais il ya plusieurs points dans le
corps qui peuvent amener ce baiser petit
millier terminaison les rovers 1 donc
effectivement de stimuler ses
terminaisons nerveuses là de la bonne
façon pour amener à vraiment
chaque match et que ma blonde tankers
c'est ainsi qu'en mettant du sexe anal
qui est qu à l'impôt en général le sexe
anal dans la pointe mais ton d'en voir
parce que c'est quand même rare souvent
que la clé mais tant que la fibre
stimuler votre toucher en même temps tu
mets ton fait le juste prix pour l a dit
moi juste voir c'est juste une
pénétration anale sa stimulation du
clitoris pour moi c'est comme
ça comme des dingues sur un tableau
je maintiens que c'est propre à chacun
ouais mais c'est encore le et c'est pour
ça aussi qu'il ya beaucoup de
pornographie lesbiennes qui regardaient
par des femmes parce que la pénétration
que ça soit anna lou que ce soit
vaginale
jeu la première à regarder et enfin le
regard depuis
les ophones sais je peux avoir du
plaisir dans la vraie vie le avec la
pénétration mais en regardant ses petits
c'est tellement un spectacle qui rit
comme si et ça c'était je voudrais donc
et y en a qui vont préférer dans la
pornographie regarder une stimulation du
clitoris qu'elle est et comme acquis le
la jet set c'est un orgasme de du fun
pour briller c'est vrai les contractions
aussi du plancher pelvien souvent puis
pack m mais oui effectivement c'est ça
peut être zappé difficile de regarder la
pénétration m oui mais magique du
probant du monde se pose aussi une
estimation en plus extrêmes
ça peut être des étudiants oui
définitivement face au défi nitivement
définitivement puis il y en a justement
qui vont une juste capable d'avoir un
orgasme
interne c'est une stimulation externe
l'on rentre dans les moeurs des statues
ornent ses façons de vendre des orgas
tmp des orgasmes et enfin qu'il ya déjà
aussi que les femmes qui vont faire la
position qu'ils sont par dessus
l'homme et qui sont sur le dessus qui
équivaudrait à manger juste un orgasme
quand je suis sur le dessus puis un
orgasme interne puis finalement ce que
ça ce que ça démontre dans le mode extra
thouarcé que c'est que frottons
guitariste et moderne ce qui fait que tu
penses que tu un orgasme et terne donc
c'est complexe c'est complexe le corps
humain mais
c'est pour avoir
vraiment un orgasme je sais pas si vous
avez déjà entendu parler du rocking
chair et là la position de la bascule la
double bascule quand on écoute il nous
met ça dans un cours à l'unité plus
c'est comme du monde qui font des
mouvements basslines prix du monde ça
c'est une mode extra thoiras privilégie
steve et atteindre l'orgasme dans le
fond mais tant qu une pénétration anale
pitt est capable de travailler ton
plancher pelvien en même temps c'est sûr
que ça va accentuer ton plaisir puis
potentiel orgasmique également parce que
c'est ton plancher pelvien encore une
fois qui est activé quand un orgasme
donc la bascule c'est d'être capable de
bouger le bassin devant derrière devant
derrière ça fait en sorte que tu as un
afflux sanguin plus important dans les
organes génitaux chez l'homme on veut le
voir avec l'érection du pénis et chez la
femme mais sa direction du guitariste
mais c'est un terme qu'on voit moins et
donc et plus tu es plutôt une érection
qui aime qui ressenti plus tu vas
ressenti ça va être plus verts réceptifs
s'y opposèrent c'était au toucher pizza
donc effectivement quand une que les
traces en alpiq été capable de faire
aller ton ton plancher pelvien d'avoir
une stimulation autres de la future
halle des organes génitaux détente et
tambellini sme par cadillac
quelqu'un qui écoute le podcast qui dit
je veux en savoir plus je veux l'oeil
2h30 une formation de deux heures et
demie sur le sexe anal qui semble sans
venir les ricains qui veut s'inscrire
qui veut participer à des
accompagnements par les conférences ou
des ateliers
qu'est ce qu'ils font est au lit avec
anne marie sur tous les réseaux sociaux
instagram c'est vraiment là que ça se
passe
sur ce secteur aussi mais ça reste un
grand mais je suis plus interactive avec
avec mon public a bien voulu aller plus
loin peuvent s'inscrire
réponse sexuelle donc si tu veux
entendre parler de désir de
communication est que ce avant des trucs
pour atteindre l'orgasme tu veux
connaître ton cycle menstruel est
généreux on a vraiment passé tous les
tous les sujets puis ça continue qui on
a des concours sur cette plateforme l'on
reçoit des expertes qui viennent nous
parler des différents sujets donc si
possible de s'inscrire c'est au lit avec
anne marie points comme c'était un mec
trouver sinon un lien je me suis
dispensé est tout tracé merci infiniment
d'une part les c'était vraiment falloir
hisser à nouveau yes c'est beaucoup
attendu un sommet le
10 comme eu un excellent tu as tout un
podcast convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le titre le pitch vous abonner pour
trop de leur part montées sont trop de
la whey trois pièces par horace par mois
et vous avez les pas de carte en avance
acquise avec les premiers de votre
groupe d'amis à recruter les podcasts
qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une
avance quand vous allez tirer la
dynamique entre les amys tout le temps
avec une avance sur les jobs en avance
les gens autour de toi mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que le
chèque le podcast su ni voulu nous
entendre jazz ou davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcasts etc là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
toucher les nicole non nicoli le
maintenant comme un fils travaille la
place travot de taza taille est là mais
on jase on parle de conversion qu'on
m'aide à voir mais ce si vous voulez
avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pétrole il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous